I really want to do stand up like I
think you would feel [__] great you
did do it bro but I was like taking the
piss though but um I'll be like my
friends and stuff they'd be saying
especially Hershey like he's real big in
the comedy he'd be saying like I could
do good but like I really want to put my
uh because I feel like if I started now
and just was like yo guys I'm going on
tour I could you know already do good
because
I don't want to do it that way you know
it's like I need to at least do like
comedy clubs for like four or five years
you want to build the art yeah I want to
go to places
and not put on my social media oh I'm
gonna be here like I just want to have
random people be there yeah and really
see like that's how you get y'all [__]
with me yeah because you'll be funny the
people who don't know you yeah and that
gets harder and harder the more famous
you get because you know everybody knows
who Chris Rock is yeah right but at the
same time like that's how you're really
gonna learn how to curate that that
craft that art it's good to have started
cut it's it's I think in entertainment
it's good to have a craft it's good to
have an art it doesn't have to be stand
up it could be the videos that you're
making but I think what happens to a lot
of people is if they don't have an art
Fame is their desire and then once they
get famous you start kissing your twin
it starts getting a little weird how
about the island boys yeah like I just
think Fame is kind of fruitless and you
don't realize that until you're famous
and you're still kind of like miserable
like they thought Fame was going to cure
all their issues or their problems or
their give them happiness and then it
doesn't and then after that they just go
okay I just need to make as much money
as possible so they just start trying to
gravitate towards a thing that makes
them money whereas if you have like a
art or a craft that you really love
you're you're always trying to push that
craft and get better at that that art so
if it's stand up that's awesome or if
it's continuing to carry the content
that you do that's awesome but
yeah I would I would say that people
were just chasing Fame tend to be pretty
miserable no definitely did you watch
Santa grown up
um I'm not gonna lie like Kevin Hart
like I really I really didn't know about
people Kev is so funny no yeah yeah I
love Kevin Hart but like
um just recently like because I used to
not like Dave Chappelle like I was like
I don't get it but then like I really
started watching it's like I see like
it's like it's like a lie like you see
you see where it's going like whenever I
watch a video it's like I I could see
what regular viewers can't see it's like
oh I see what they're doing there I see
where they're taking this and then it's
like now like I I can't see it fully
like you guys can but like I'm starting
to see how like like the setup way
before and the transitions yeah and just
like the smoothness of everything and so
it's just like like really watching him
and like count I think probably my
favorite right now is like Cat Williams
yeah it's incredible yeah and um I'm
just like really just like trying to
like take notes and just see like that
who who
O'Neil oh that's Hershey's favorite yeah
Patrice is the goat that's the goal yeah
that's the greatest of all time it's
crazy because like uh then he like
he was like the guy who like really took
a stand for comedy when like it was
about to like because I think someone
made like a a rape joke or something he
was on like Fox News yeah yeah I mean he
just defended the art of the joke and
he's like you have to let us try yeah
you have to let us try to be funny it
doesn't matter how [__] up it is and
in the beginning it might not work but
we have the right to try yeah because
eventually when we keep trying we're
gonna it's like a sword you're just
gonna keep on banging away at it and
then it's gonna get sharp you don't have
to laugh at it but don't but you have to
you can't take away our right to try and
uh but yeah he was just a brilliant
[__] dude I mean he's got like I mean
there's the elephant in the room I think
is probably on Netflix isn't it maybe no
it's not Instagram it's on YouTube on
YouTube on YouTube but then he's got a
bunch of like audio things he came out
right before he passed away called Mr P
that's like he's just yeah he's prolific
he's just prolific he did comedy would
you try to keep it clean or talk about
all the girls you [__]
definitely all the girls
it's not a scoop up my comedy show
I think you'd be a really good standard
because the more I stuff of yours I
watch listen to you beyond the pranks
even you're a you're a deep kid you're
22. it's really [__] impressive how
mature you are How Deeply you think
about things appreciate it and I think
that combined with funny that is the the
fundamental things you need to be a
great stand-up so I think if you really
went after it and like Andrew said you
got to be it's good you wouldn't
announce your shows because if you start
chasing the bag you might feel pressured
it's going to take a few years in a
different way it's gonna take a few
years to even get to the point where you
can get on there and it's like it
shouldn't be something you're doing for
money in the beginning yeah because
that's going to pressure you and you're
like oh [__] I need to just get this 30
minutes because if I have 30 minutes and
I can get 40 000 for that gig it should
be I'm going to take as much time as I
need to get 15 minutes or five minutes
or three minutes whatever it is just
take the [__] time if it's something
you really want to do yeah in fact try
it you might hate that [__] yeah it's
painful bro that's another thing bro
how do you think it's scary that's right
you don't understand it that's a crazy
he's gone on stage and done jokes and
then he's like man stand would be crazy
it's like you've dealt with that
pressure before you know what I mean not
really because like I because the video
was I went up there like telling
horrible jokes like the goal was to be
bad yeah yeah so bombing didn't feel bad
it felt like he succeeded right yeah
yeah for me it was a w and like the
great thing about it was people in the
comments were like damn you were looking
funnier than the guys before you I I
applaud people that went up there and
tried though because it's just like I
really just saw like oh man I'm like it
was this one joke Brody was like yeah I
was shopping for watermelons and I was
stealing them he's like but it's hard to
steal in rollerblades they're like hey
stop you can't get those and he just
goes
and then why it was just so quiet
and I'm like I was laughing but I was
laughing because of how quiet it was
that's why it was funny but I was just
like damn like if I I was thinking about
it I was like if I do try this like I'm
not [__] like that happen where [__]
are like I'm gonna say a joke and
soldiers
hit me with one of those like yeah yeah
you have to embrace that it will happen
yeah no matter what no matter how long
you've been doing it you'll still catch
slow ones yeah just part of it we were
talking about this at uh during uh The
Green Room during the shows this weekend
there was like a generational Rift in
like what we find funny or how comedy is
uh projected into the world okay
um I'm 39 right so when I'm growing up
people on TV that were funny were trying
to be funny yeah
Jim Carrey was trying to be funny
everybody was trying to be funny and I
think it was Derek who said this or
maybe it was you that said it an
interesting observation he's like yeah I
think the office changed that I go what
do you mean oh [__] love the office
exactly and what is the difference with
the office right the difference with the
office like in Seinfeld Kramer is trying
to walk in the room funny yeah walk in
the room he's trying to be crazy there's
a lap track it's going hey you need to
laugh now and then the office comes out
and that [__] Michael Scott is
not trying to be funny no he is just
that weird kind of almost cringe guy the
things he's saying is Christian and then
the generation that watches that show
and subsequent shows finds cringe stuff
really funny because that's what curated
their sense of humor it's funny when
someone is not trying to be funny and
they do something so awkward it's
hilarious yeah and a lot of your pranks
are the people think you're dead serious
so we're laughing at those people
reacting to you being cringed in that
moment yeah a lot of people they say
like uh they'll be like man this was a
hard watch good job great job that's
what people like and it's a generational
Rift and it might have been the office
there are other things that are
obviously inspired by the office other
films but I didn't even realize it till
we have that discussion in The Green
Room like how our generation Jamie Foxx
was trying to be funny in The Jamie Foxx
yeah so funny every time he came on
screen and he succeeded it he was
[__] hilarious yeah and I wonder how
that affects how you guys will do
stand-up
because stand up isn't
isn't trying to not be funny
you could make fun of stand up and those
are like the alternative guys sometimes
they have some success but stand up
needs to be so mainstream for those them
to succeed the entire population needs
to know what stand-up is for somebody to
be making fun of it yeah usually
economy's pretty fringe so to make fun
of it you just
drafting off of the people who know what
it is uh-huh does that make sense a
little bit Yeah so like like for example
let's say somebody was like making fun
of streamers first streamers needs to be
mainstream in order for us to get the
jokes of making fun of us oh okay do you
know what I mean okay yeah but if
streaming is fringe which now is very
popular but if it's Fringe how many
people can even get the joke of you
making fun everybody got to be in on it
to get it when you make fun of it when
you're making fun of it yeah yeah but
it's interesting the office so you came
up on that that's oh bro I'll probably
watch the office like
15 times over bro it's it's I think it's
one of the because
it doesn't try you know there's no live
track it's no it's the the zoom ins the
awkwardness and I I I guess I low-key
try to do that with the videos it's just
like oh it's awkward like you know it's
not I'm not necessarily trying to be
funny it's just like how can we make
this situation just like so
uncomfortable just awkward yeah and then
it's just like it's just fun like that
because that's that's what's funny to me
yeah that's my type of sense of humor I
I'm not as good at that I remember
bridesmaids it's so built on just being
awkward there's moments where I'm like
yo I can't do this like it just changes
like now I don't know if you've seen
that but there's a moment where they're
like trying to one-up each other these
two bridesmaids are trying to like
one-up each other in their wedding
speeches for the bride and it just keeps
getting more and more awkward and more
and more embarrassing for them and
you're just I'm watching like Brad can't
make it through this I [__] can't
handle it yeah the officers moments
where I'm like yo I can't watch this
episode Scott's tots Scott's tots is too
hot [__] was hilarious all the time this
episode you haven't seen the office
Michael Scott promises all these kids
when they're like 5 five years old if
you go to college I'll pay for it if you
graduate high school I'll pay for your
college they all graduate throw him this
huge thing and then he has to tell them
I'm not paying for your college I'm not
I just can't so that's the whole episode
there is no heartwarming moment that's
the episode I can't do it I skipped that
episode I can't do it he was like I
thought it was going to be like a
multi-millionaire by the time I was 35.
and I thought I was gonna do it and then
he gave them all computer batteries
because that's what he could afford he's
like you guys all the charges for your
bed I didn't remember that because I
can't watch they made him a theme song
when he first came in like they were
happy before happy to see him yeah
there's so many different examples of
that I wish I could find some more shows
like you watch Nathan for you Nathan
Zoom
[Laughter]
keeping it and we leave it in the
episode
but yeah like Nico makes videos like
that where it's just like over the top
and like I love but I just can't do that
stuff because it's like whenever I like
think too much about it it never comes
out good for me so just kind of like we
just run and Gun it you need it to be
raw yeah like we uh we pulled up to
Gatorade HQ okay so we had uh we had
prime and we have these fake Gatorade
bottles and we put Prime in it and I
bullshitted my way all the way to the
top of the Pepsi HQ and I had like uh
Gatorade employees tried one of it was
called IMAP USA so whenever they said it
sounds like they said I'm a [__] and
like uh it was like uh I spice and walk
and all this that's funny it was just
like it was no big elaborate plan of
like oh we're gonna do this this this it
was just yeah I was just gonna talk to
someone just see how far we can get yeah
yeah and that's just how I am like I
feel like that's just the best for me